well Kenya's president says a terror
attack that lasted for 19 hours is over
this morning attackers targeted a luxury
hotel complex in Nairobi yesterday
killing at least 14 people one of them
is an American identified as Jason
Spindler Deborah pocha is in Nairobi
with the latest
Deborah good morning good morning we
here at the city morgue where family
members are lining up to identify loved
ones the blue vehicle you can see behind
me has just arrived to transfer the body
of Jason spender
to a private funeral home he ran a
development agency here in Nairobi and
according to social media was a 9/11
survivor the attack began yesterday
afternoon when militants stormed the
Dusit Hotel and office complex
armed with bombs and guns chilling CCTV
footage shows at least four gunmen
hunting for prey they moved with
military precision through the complex
taking their time firing
indiscriminately along the way Jerrod
office workers fled the scene taking
cover wherever they could
some never stood a chance sporadic
gunfire could still be heard at the
complex earlier today despite police
claims they had everything under control
and scores of people were still being
escorted to safety in the early hours of
the morning it was thought that at least
one gunman remained on the loose
authorities now say all the attackers
have been killed survivors could hardly
believe they'd made it out alive I don't
have words I just say thank God that you
are okay and everyone had a nightmarish
tale to tell and then gosh also just
being spread all over I don't know from
the top I think they went to the top
floor and then decided spring bullets
the al-qaeda-linked al-shabaab group has
claimed responsibility for the attack
the worst since they struck at the heart
of the capital in 2013 at the Westgate
Mall which killed at least 67 people
such desperately sag fiends here at the
city mall as family members collapse and
grief after identifying loved ones the
official death toll stands at 14 but
looking at the numbers here that could
possibly rise Gail Debora patta
reporting from Nairobi thank you